就这么一个特别简单动作
你就能赚到钱
我告诉你该怎么做
这是一个真实的呀
上周诺的时候
我们那边回忆
我们很多老婆也都知道
老婆也都讲了
分享了一个他
专家小钱的一个案例
他自己也没想到
就是他在国外的晚上看到一个叫白炸银
觉得特别好
他就在国内的这个晚上搜
早半天找不到
然后自己好被找到了
找了以后的方法突然想
这个
这个别人是不是会也会遇到呢
他就把自己在
网上搜到一些
就没有版钱的
白炸银就打包了
打包了以后他随手挂到模板了
结果也没做推广
然后就用回来了
越来越多越来越多
后来他三十把他这个做成就特上
就为什么要做这样的案例
因为这种案例是真实的
是听着我们老百姓的
而且你基本上就能做
就把一个什么东西
觉得对边有用
直接放到膀上上
然后就卖着去了
这是一套非常有效的方法
我告诉大家每个步骤该怎么做
现在里面是有方法论的
而且很论之所以没有做成实因为
一个是不知道该怎么做另外一个的话呢就是
受限了所以我跟他分享一下
拿个名叫白炸
打包的正量吧
准两半以后的话呢
再去中的一半你就想
你随意想你想到什么你写什么
就是你遇到的不爽的事情啊你不开心的事情啊
什么事一直做一直没有成果呀对吧
然后呢
你已经想要什么东西带你没有的
我给大家求过了一个
比如说我们就随便举过令人啊今天来说
作白没说好
一条
加条
那个
早上没精神
吞上茂汉
一直想见谁见
讲不下去
然后
最近没有灵感
现入个平静里面出来
然后呢
做事的时候经常被党断
然后呢姑娘
做事不还遵住
想到什么就消息了什么
就写出实条来
写出实条来
我觉得说我写不出实条来那个写二条
那些不说二条怎么办些中一百条什么意思
就说我们很运做这个事情了
就老想的是因此就把它做好
而且这些东西这个不好这个不好这个
不要批判
想到啥就写啥
这个就好像什么呢
就好像很运打那个枪
还没有没有没有没有办法你
包一枪
准备打中
还是哪个枪
帮帮帮帮帮帮
一顿乱枪
对吧
它中有一枪有可能就
就感到应对吧
所以一个人记住
您现在有一个好主意的方法
是仙拥有一百个造包的主意
你就把这个主意把它列出来
仙拥是了
仙不管的仙不不出来
然后如果不行
过来明天在地
后天在地
就没事
有空的时候
花个三分钟五分钟
就赶那个事
能能利用的一色
内容了以后的话
看看哪个不合适的花掉
哪个是合适的
哪个是合适的有可能
然后你把它做出来
很多时候就是生活中的一个
小问题叫做做
比如说你想不不说
就是因为打得到说
打不出来说
这个打不出来怎么办
就做得不不不然
对吧
还有那个带他知道那个随便罚吗
就是在学校的时候
找工作找不到
后来怎么办
然后那我搞一个学片吧
你就像我个人来说
很多老婆就说
不知道7分怎么读
对吧
然后从哪儿的或许信息
然后怎么猜也怎么读不着
所以我做了一个江湖之邦
对吧
包括我遇到很多老婆的问题
然后把那些问题整理出来
我就习得说
叫加持新吧
对吧
遇到什么当问题
你就想到了
你就把它写出来
写完了以后
注意
这边左车就是你的想法
就是遇到的处置
困难
不耍的地方
别人遇到的东西
把它写出来
然后
华在有一些觉得没意思的
在这边右边那个部分
注意啊
不是想好几个方案他去做
我们很多人都有一个缺陷
就是我要想好那个玩人的几个方案
就做
我告诉你想的想的
你就进入陷阱了
也还有一个悠疑
对吧
我告诉你最后的方法
不是想到一个方法的地方
而是想到第一不该怎么做
先把第一不做的在说
九例子啊
比如说RBB
就是看他这个酒店
没有人
就很多人没酒店做的
怎么办
那我要的第一不是怎么做
不去想做什么
我做个红围的冷战
然后招聘
我足够办公室
不是
就是把自己压那个床
拍一张照片
配个文字
告诉你
我们家床外出租
我还会有个早饭
那放了忙那张
就这么一个简单动作
对吧
那你做完了以后的话
那结果没想到
RBB他就好了
我自己特别喜欢的
一个RB什么的
就不免身
大家都知道
就是这个面去做飞机
结果那个飞机搬掉
他就很不爽
他就想
我能不能我自己搞个
搞个这个航公司
但他本人就是一个
出版社了
对吧
去拿着飞机
没飞机
文文足一个飞机
你看他没有想那么多
没有想那么复杂
说好
怎么去做飞机
给玻璃木散的话
对吧
很多时候那你啥
也不是你
也不用打电话人拒绝的
对呀
就很费量有可能拒绝
但他就打那个电话
人家就切他了
然后这个航公司就出来了
所以很多时候
就是
你想到那个什么东西
然后你有一个动作
第一个动作做了
然后这个事
就会有反馈
有个反馈就会有
第二个动作
就会有第三个动作
我知道很多人会说什么问题
就是班医失败来怎么办
就我们有失败的成本啊
对不对
我每次讲这个是一段时候
可能就是个
就是个失败的成本啊
对吧
好
那我告诉你个方法
他是真是发生的这口
我自己也硬盘这么做
我不知道你平时是不是会和朋友去餐
或者和朋友许战
或者说出一吃外
有个朋友来来了以后
你可以着带他
我不知道你订阅的话你吃多少
可能是五百
可能这是一切
你像我今天只会知道 Adding点一千多
好
你把他的设设一个 Brother
叫他亲戶吃饭的 Brother
你平时
每天想他
如果没玩笑
没空上有空上说 想想 专位声音来说 想想
这个发呆的时候 想想 做的工交车上说 想一想
对吧 然后华调 好右边就是第一步
那么第一步以出来 只要这个第一步 你一看
它是不是低于你请客吃饭的钱
是不是低于你请客吃饭的钱
是低于你请客吃饭的钱 那好了
相当于 我不行客了 我做这个事了 可不可以
我去做一个尝试 就很多事情的成本是非常低的
没你们想的那么可怕
很多时候 你想了越多越可怕
然后最后你会发现你不做的
对吧 你比如说 像我们那个老火箭
就是把一个
我们把你学的音乐打个包放到往那上挂的
它自己都没想到 对吧
也不做推掉 然后来的人越来越多 越来越多
是不是 很多事情就是只要成本低
然后你就可以去尝试
就好了 这是我说的第二个部分
大破大的一个认知前景
然后第三件事情 我跟大家讲
就是你们要学会给自己挂虚张
就很多人的话 有个什么样的虚张
就是我来把一个生作成
我做上一个相比的作品 上一个什么相比
我刚才你一个更好的虚张
就要失败光刺
我叫他失败一百将军
就是我要失败一百刺
什么意思呢 就说我做个谁
我突然想到了
我这个东西能不能挂到往那上呢
我 我实施 对吧
好 这个事情没成功 不要紧
成本很低吧
最多一会请人吃饭的事了
最重要 我不请了
失败一刺
接下来 我失败了一刺
失败了两次 失败了三次 失败了四败了四败了五次
失败一百刺 这是个终于
失败了一百刺
这是个终于 你们大会游戏面
是吧 失败一百刺是个终于
你要去集体这一百个终于
这一百个终于其实意味着你的成长
意味着你的经验 意味着你开始
不断的结极问题的问题的本身 对吧
我不知道大家没有玩过这个投伏游戏
玩过投伏游戏 什么投伏游戏呢
给你个举个例子 那个虎 这百个戒
描了 我给你把近一点 特别好的戒
然后的话你去描给你
给你无限长的时间 二十四小时 过不高
四十八小时 过不高 好
怕开始偷 你说他重的可能性大还是不重的可能性大
我给你讲 如果人一个人只能偷一次
他可以描着二十四个小时 他就站在那个位置
我给他 我给你讲 来一百个人不斗 一百次
他偷不进去
当然很可能会有一次偷进去的 对吧
那我还在天 快给你吧
但是另外大部分来说是偷不进去的
但是我没给你机会 我怕给你一百之间
一百之间 对吧
放在一放 不认许描着 你就往里面偷吧
有 你说你让我偷一顿色 有没有可能周一次
各位 你体会一想
有些时候的话呢
这个叫做飞顿成博异 什么叫做飞顿成博异呢
就是你失败的时候
你付出的成博异基地 就像我们的老婆一样
这个东西 我把我找到的一些免费的一些白道音
大高宝 发到那个宝博异上
你说这里面有什么成博异吗
我失败的成博异基地
但是我获得收益到的时候
那你就不断的反复的大量做这个事
最后我得得拿捕异异 就是我个人投资 最近你应该总结的一个经验
这个经验对我投资特别特别有帮助
就是你不要一直证捷
你没有必要一直证捷
甚至大多数情况下 你都是错的
但是 你只要保证你错的时候的成本基地
可能是一顿饭钱 甚至比对面钱还低
但是你获胜的时候 你的收益基地高的时候
这个才是时候就代表你真正的开始理解 该怎么做事 怎么投资呢